boxer shorts were introduced in the
1920s for well boxers this underwear was
loose around the legs giving boxers the
freedom that they needed to move around
the ring then about a decade later
briefs came into the world offering a
sleeker tighter fitting option and
sparking a now classic question boxers
or briefs and as it turns out there may
be a clear winner after all you read
that right wearing tight underwear can
lower your sperm count turns out if
underwear is too tight it pushes the
testicles closer to the body increasing
their temperature in the process and
that's bad news for the sperm inside you
see a man's sperm production is at its
best when his testicles are cooler than
his core body temperature two to four
degrees Celsius cooler to be exact
that's why the testes hang down away
from the body for most mammals so when
you wear tight underwear the resulting
increase in temperature can damage the
sperm and potentially your fertility as
well scientists have been studying the
link between body heat and fertility for
years several studies show that men who
work under hot conditions like bakers
and ceramic oven operators are more
likely to have fertility issues than men
who work cooler jobs but ovens of course
are much much warmer than the human body
so it wasn't until recently that
researchers discovered that yes even
small increases in temperature from
wearing tight underwear can cause
problems in 2018 Harvard researchers
released the largest study on the
subject to date
they analyzed 656 men seeking treatment
at fertility centers and recorded their
daily underwear preference boxers or non
boxers like briefs and jockeys sure
enough men who wore boxers had 33% more
mobile sperm you know the kind that can
swim successfully fertilize an egg they
also just had more sperm in general
about 25% more in their collected
samples but researchers also found
something they weren't expecting
ding men in the non boxers group had
higher levels of something called a
follicle stimulating hormone or FSH FSH
is released by the pituitary gland to
help boost sperm production in the
testes so researchers think that an
increase in FSH levels could be the
body's way of compensating for low sperm
production and while both groups of men
still had plenty of sperm needed to
conceive a child researchers found that
tight underwear could jeopardize the
fertility of men who already suffer from
low sperm counts luckily young healthy
men tend to produce sperm continuously
so it's possible to reverse damage
caused by wearing tight underwear simply
by switching to a less confining option
[Music]